what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are jumping into our x-men
chronology and I'm not sure what day I'm
gonna upload this on but whatever day it
ends up being will probably just be our
x-men day x-man I've been reading
forever I mean it's the first you know
one of the very first comics that really
got me into comic books per se the first
comic I ever owned was sovereign 7 and
something by Batman although I cannot
remember what in the world it was
there's an old Batman comic and I can't
remember what it was but the villain was
like this guy that were all black and he
had like sharp claws it looked like and
like you tried to drown Batman in like
the sewers I think maybe it was after
nightfall I'm not a hundred percent sure
I mean I'm pretty sure it was but I
remember if it was Bruce Wayne Batman or
if it was like John Paul Valle Batman
but I cannot remember for the life of me
but it was just a Batman comic and I
know it's a needle in a haystack
considering we've got nine hundred
some-odd Detective Comics and god only
knows how many hundreds of Batman comics
but I've been trying to figure out what
in the world that is I'm trying to
figure it out forever so if anybody
knows if just on that little description
alone you have an idea of what I'm
referencing post it down in the comments
I will be checking so hopefully somebody
has it but when it comes to the x-men
it's interesting because the x-men have
existed in Marvel Comics for a decade
the problem with this was that with
Chris Claremont riding the x-men for 17
years after he left after Gimli left as
artists in the early 90s the x-men just
sort of began to falter because nobody
was really able to bring the kind of
character development to the x-men
comics that Chris Claremont was able to
do this was compounded by the mid 1990s
comic bus and we don't need to go into
that suffice it to say it was a point
whereby marvel almost went bankrupt and
so by the early 2000s Marvel was
basically reshuffling everything and the
result was that we got something called
x-men reload now x-men reload was this
mid 2000s initiative that was really
kind of this idea of just reshuffling
the whole x-men mythos and then just
kind of boiling it down to its core
roots because over the course of the 17
years Chris Claremont wrote the x-men
over the course of the subsequent years
and other writers like Scott Liddell and
you know Grant Morrison and so on and so
forth what the x-men the issue was you
would get mutants who would be rolled
into a story they would appear once and
they would never be seen or heard from
again and the problem that Marvel faced
was that the number of mutants out there
had just grown too high and so because
of that x-men reload was designed to
literally reduce the number of mutants
down to the most popular characters
that's why we got the event called House
of M it was designed to basically
eliminate
so many mutants that were there and just
boil it down to its core roots and so
following the events of house of M we
got this sort of branding initiative
called decimation and so with uncanny
x-men what this does is this picks up
with the fall of the Grays and I
remember with our x-men days we're
covering almost everything so you guys
will basically find out what all was
happening unlike the x-men universe side
of things of Marvel Comics we've done
with almost everybody else to this point
I mean we're in the process of doing it
with Avengers and New Avengers we've
done it with Captain America we've done
it with Ironman we've done with
spider-man because of that with death of
the grace this is designed to actually
wrap up in a lot of ways the character
of Rachel summers none of the sense of
it's gonna kill her off but in the sense
that is basically sort of allowing her
to quote-unquote start anew now under
normal circumstances I probably wouldn't
have covered this but Rachel summers is
gonna have a pretty significant role
once we get to the story of x-men deadly
Genesis which basically brings back the
character of Vulcan which is the third
summer's brother who's an omega-level
mutant but Rachel summers will be the
means by which he basically learns
everything that's going on but with
Rachel summers she's really really
intriguing
so in Marvel Comics as most of you guys
probably know they had a story called
x-men Days of Future Passed an x-men
Days of Future past at the time that it
was written was basically a worst-case
scenario right it was the answer to the
question what if the x-men failed
what if Charles Xavier more macabre the
mutant geneticists and what if a
political figure Senator Robert Kelley
who were all taken out by the
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants what would
humanity's response to that be well of
course as we know from the story
humanity responded by restarting the
Sentinel program
the Sentinels became autonomous they
conquered the entirety of North America
humans and mutants alike and set their
sights on the world
and so the story was kind of a race
against time because it was the idea
that the very various European nations
had effectively bonded under one goal of
eliminating the Sentinel threat or North
America so it wouldn't infect anything
else and so they were basically
launching nuclear weapons at the US the
result is that Canada the United States
all these different territories were at
risk of being totally obliterated and so
you basically had the efforts of a
handful of mutants who had survived and
we're living in internment camps that
were trying to keep this from happening
Rachel summers is one of them now the
way in which this timeline fits in is a
little bit weird so bear with me here
for a second and Marvel Comics when you
see a story that takes place in the
future for the most part that's the
guaranteed future usually the story
involves somebody going back and
changing things
Days of Future past was a story where
the Sentinels conquered North America
and so the question had to be asked if
that was a future where sentinels
conquered North America and they were
trying to stop that future then what
happens to it when they succeed to that
universe where the Sentinels conquered
North America it becomes an alternate
reality is exactly what it does and so
essentially with KT prides mind being
sent to the past one of the x-men what
was going to happen and ultimately
saving the day
it meant the Days of Future past future
became an alternate reality the future
was unwritten we had no no indication of
what the future was going to be until
somebody came along and wrote a story
that involved the future and the Days of
Future past reality Jean Grey and M
cyclops had had a child and that child's
name was Rachel summers but Rachel
summers like her mom was a telepath and
telekinetic and that was it that was
really all there was to record her
initially but she was the one who sent
the mine of Kitty Pryde into the past
and warned the x-men the date of Future
Passed would happen and what would start
that whole process the problem with this
was that because it became an alternate
reality the future was basically
unchanged in that universe Days of
Future past progressed just like it did
the long and short of this is that
because Rachel summers basically looked
around and realized the future didn't
change the question was why why is her
world still the same and so what ended
up happening is Marvel wrote a story
called days of future present and what
that was designed to do was role Rachel
summers into the main Marvel Universe
and so what she ended up doing was in
truth basically jumping from her own
universe
into the main Marvel Universe and into
the past of the main Marvel Universe and
so the result was that we basically got
this new character who was the daughter
of Jean Grey now all of this came out of
the death of Jean came out of the
Phoenix saga the Dark Phoenix saga so on
and so forth so Jean Grey had been dead
for quite some time you know she had
been gone for a little while and then of
course she ended up coming back as we
all know but the idea of bringing Rachel
into the fray and you know really kind
of brought in a new dynamic and it was
really interesting following Chris
Claremont leaving the title she just
sort of bounced around from one story to
the next and nobody ever really fleshed
her out there were a couple times when
she went to go visit the home of Jean
Grey but she never really tried to bond
with the family or anything along those
lines and so following the events of
house of M because of the fact that
Rachel Summers was basically in the
white hot room which is to say this sort
of multiversal space meaning that when
house have been happened and all the
mutants lost her powers she was
unaffected when she showed back up in
the main Marvel Universe she realized
everything had just sort of gone to pot
and so what this did has a kind of
Center on an existential crisis because
deal with her
a mutant and so many mutants having lost
her powers and her having been you know
one of the few who retained her own that
it you really get kind of you know
inspired this desire to travel back and
visit her family now remember this is
not Rachel's real family and I say that
because of the fact that she's from a
different universe she's the daughter
and Jean Grey and Scott Summers from an
alternate reality so but the bonding
process happens almost immediately I
mean basically she kind of shows that
God she starts talking everybody and
this has been something that I've been a
long time in coming I mean she'd met
them like once or twice but they knew
who she was I mean in terms of her being
the daughter of Jean and Scott you know
from a different universe and so on and
so forth but it was cool because this
bonding basically gives her a home that
she never experienced before because one
of the things about Rachel is that
because she was universally displaced
and meant that she didn't really have a
home of her own but for her it wasn't
that bad because the home she came from
was was awful but the cool thing is that
with her bonding with everybody learning
about her own past talking to various
people one of the other people that she
comes into contact with is basically her
grandma and the irony of all this is
that her grandma doesn't like Rachel she
hates Rachel in every sense of the word
but a lot of this really stems back to
you know this woman and her husband
giving up Jean Grey to Charles Xavier
now remember at the time when Jean first
started to manifest her powers it was
one of those those things where no
parent really knew what to do because
Jean Grey was one of the first of a
handful of mutants that publicly began
to display powers so it's not like her
parents had a template it's not like
they knew where to go Charles Xavier
popping up and basically saying I run a
school for gifted children for people
that have abilities like your daughter's
I can help your daughter cope with her
powers so on and so forth it was a
welcoming thing the problem with this
was that Jean Grey's experience as a lot
of us know as part of the x-men was
tumultuous she was the weakest member of
the team she eventually was catapulted
to the strongest member of the team she
was a harbinger or a possessor of the
Phoenix force she died she was
resurrected she died again she was
resurrected and then finally died I mean
a lot of these things started taking
place with her character bouncing around
all these sort of scenarios happening
but at the end of the day her parents
were largely left in the dark they
weren't really told everything that was
going on instead they would just see
their daughter on TV fighting crime they
would learn that their daughter had died
and so it created a really strange sort
of scenario you know Rachel summers
being there basically reminds the
parents of Jean Grey of all the things
they missed out on and the idea that it
may very well have been a mistake to a
mile gene to go with Charles Xavier so
again you know she's very much a
reminder of the mistakes they feel
they've made and so ultimately what
happening as there's this massive family
reunion that takes place and is cool
because Rachel gets to meet all these
members of her extended family that she
never knew about before the problem with
this is that almost immediately after
this this family you know begins to have
their whole get-together people start
dying rapidly and it all happens within
the span of 24 seconds from right now
until I say that we've moved on
everything that we talked about happens
in the span of 24 seconds first member
of the family dies John grey following
that we end up having Fred Harriman he
ends up dying too all these members are
killed from being impaled they're killed
from having all these assassins start
jumping in out of nowhere and they all
start died we have Nightcrawler who
immediately teleports in alongside a
handful of other x-men you know getting
people out as best they can and the
reason for this is because of the fact
that when Rachel summers immediately
starts realizing that people are dying
she sends out a kind of psychic backlash
now this is kind of a a side effect you
know so to speak for lack of a better
word of her being in the situation that
she's in remember Rachel summer is
having operated having lived in Days of
Future past hardened her in a lot of
different ways
she was combat trained combat focused
and so in this scenario when you
suddenly have all these greys dying you
know that so far happened in the span of
eight seconds Rachel panics this massive
psychic backlash that goes out hits Emma
Frost first Emma Frost immediately picks
up what's happening alerts the x-men
Nightcrawler teleports in all that
happens in the span of eight seconds and
so it's crazy because these assassins
take no prisoners they're there for one
goal and that goal is to take out every
single member of the gray family they
can find this is a very powerful and a
very capable group and the reason why is
because this group is part of the Shiar
Empire they're basically an elite squad
of assassins they were sent here for the
purpose of eliminating what was left of
the Sommers line now remember Rachel is
not a weakling she's not a person easily
taken out and by all standards of
measurement by this you know she our
assassin group they can't really kill
her she's still in possession of the
Phoenix force to a degree and the result
is that she can't be killed through
traditional means instead what they do
is they effectively brand her and what
this means is they'll be able to find
her anywhere in the universe no matter
where she goes now the other half of
this is that because this is a she our
elite guard this allows us to sort of
bring in a discussion about the Shiar
now in Marvel Comics you got a lot of
different empires that exist out there
humanity is just a bunch of folks who
live on earth and there's some really
powerful people but that's it we reside
on one planet most people don't even
know about the various alien races that
are out there and so does she our Empire
is a massive Empire it basically spans
almost the entirety of its galaxy
consisting of thousands and thousands of
worlds but they are an amalgamation of
racism you know unlike the the Scrolls
which is basically the scroll Empire and
they're all Scrolls the Shiar is a
variety of different races who have all
sworn fealty to the to the magistrate's
or the Magister whoever it is that's
running the show at the time but this
assassin group going through is is
designed for one purpose to take out
these various people now the x-men are a
threat but at the end of the day they're
not necessarily undefeatable by this
group and in fact because of the fact
that the x-men have faced off against
the Shiar Empire at different points
over the course of their publication
history what this means is that the
Shiar does have a pretty solid
understanding of how to get into earth
deal with the various superheroes who
were there how to avoid them if at all
possible how to get their target and how
to leave without being being seen the
problem is they didn't really Bank on
Rachel summers being there and that was
the cog in the wheel broke the whole
scenario wide open the other half of
this is that the grandmother of Rachel
summers the mother of Jean Grey despises
her existence and this is one of the
crazy scenarios because her mother is
basically grieving within the span of 24
seconds which you know we've basically
ended this 24 seconds every single
member of her family has been totally
obliterated they've been totally wiped
out destroyed in a multitude of
different ways it happened so fast that
half the people who were there didn't
even know what was happening before they
died the whole idea of Elaine looking
around and saying everything I know and
love is gone and it's because of you she
blames Rachel the cool thing about this
is her blame is not necessarily
misplaced while Jean Grey was the
Phoenix force and while Jean Grey had
died following the battle between the
x-men and the Shiar Imperial Guard
during the original you know Phoenix and
Dark Phoenix saga what this meant was
that the Shiar Empire was largely
hands-off the problem with this was that
when Rachel summers appeared and then
basically wielded the Phoenix force for
the first time what it meant is that the
Phoenix cannot only be possessed by Jean
Grey it can be possessed by the
bloodline of Jean Grey and that
presented a whole new credible threat
because with the Shiar Empire look to
the Phoenix force and see
as a harbinger of the end of all things
meaning when the Phoenix force if it
loses its mind it'll destroy all that is
the Shiar Empire is operating in the
preservation of the universe but if
Rachel grey can have the Phoenix force
Rachel grace child could have the
Phoenix force and her grandchild can
have the Phoenix force and so on and so
forth and so even if jean grey was able
to maintain control to a degree
even if jean grey was a benign host for
the Phoenix force even if Rachel hasn't
necessarily displayed herself as an
overt villain with the Phoenix force it
does not mean that a grandchild or a
great grandchild or some descendant
later on down the line would basically
use the power of the Phoenix to destroy
everything in the universe and so this
is an act of preservation by the Shiar
Empire is not an act of aggression in
the sense of being rooted in malice and
so because of this the anger of lane is
not misplaced
Rachel summers is a good person she is a
hero but she's the cause of all this
whether it was her intention or not is
irrelevant the fact is her actions
brought this down on everyone now of
course with the rest of the x-men
showing up the battle is a foregone
conclusion there's no possible way for
this Shiar assassin group to possibly
succeed it's not gonna happen as a
result these Shia are assassins group
basically bails out and they essentially
just take off and so what ends up
happening here is this religious sort of
this bonding moment between Rachel and
Scott Summers and when it came to Rachel
and when it came to Cyclops their
bonding was strong insofar as they were
more friends as opposed to father and
daughter and it's been that way with the
offspring of Cyclops and Jean in a lot
of different ways
Kable who was time displaced and came
back to the present day the relationship
between the two was very strenuous at
first it was really one of those things
where cable was more like look your
emotional attachment is a distraction
and I've got a mission to fulfill so
I'll catch you later
while you did know they were father and
son albeit cable looking vastly older
than his biological dad they weren't
didn't really bond as a father and son
only did it took quite some time in
Marvel comics before that was fleshed
out but it was interesting because with
the character of Rachel she never really
bonded on the same level I mean she did
to a degree but it was really one of
those things where it was hard for her
and Jean Grae to bond together it was
hard for her and Cyclops to bond
together because Rachel represented a
future where they died and everything
had failed she represented the worst
case scenario for everything the x-men
did as basically all for nothing so it
sort of is sort of interesting
problem with this is the story sort of
putters out it sort of ends in a
lackluster way in this sense that Jean
Grey basically takes her family into the
white-hot room that afterlife more or
less that's really kind of it the reason
why I say this is kind of lackluster is
because I mean with with the white-hot
room it's weird
so okay here's one thing I want to flesh
out in this for you I want to talk about
this for a second I want to talk about
the afterlife in Marvel Comics Marvel
has depicted the afterlife in a variety
of different ways where does an average
person go when they die in the Marvel
Universe so originally you just had
hella and Marvel coming so I know this
high levels nothing to do with the x-men
but bear with me for a second originally
you just had a helot and when the old
Stanley Jack Kirby's stories were
detailing you know tales of Asgard and
you know that Oz Guardian mythos
basically anybody who died went to the
realm of hella and that was it those
individuals who died in battle
they went to about how when mistress
death came along then it was basically
an argument of okay we have to split the
difference we have to find a way to
reconcile the tube so what Marvel said
is you have the realm of mistress death
and you have the realm of hella hella
takes the souls of those individuals who
believe in Asgard but did not die an
honorable death those individuals who
believed in Asgard and did die an
honorable death in battle presumably
they've got about how everybody else
goes to the realm of mistress death and
that's it well then you had Chris
Claremont come along and he started
riding the x-men Jean Grey becomes the
Phoenix and she learns about the white
hot room which is depicted as one of the
various iterations of death and so then
that question becomes how does that
reconcile into everything now if I
remember correctly Jean Grey met with a
guy when she was in the afterlife and
that guy I think was an aspect of
mistress death and it was basically
mistress death saying that when people
are in the afterlife how they perceived
that afterlife is contextual based on
the life they live so not everybody goes
to like heaven not everybody goes to
like Hell or someplace like that but
then again you also have all those
realms that exist out there you've got
the realm of Mephisto basically this
demon entity who takes the souls of
those he tricks you've got a heaven in
Marvel Comics you've got an actual Hell
in Marvel Comics
there really hasn't been this sort of
consolidation and Marvel about how all
those things intertwine and how all
those things
reconcile with one another and so the
white-hot room is just kind of this
place where the Phoenix goes to do its
work and that's really yet that was the
explanation that was given by Grant
Morrison that was the explanation that
was continued by Greg Pak during Phoenix
in song but the general gist of this
from what I've been able to grasp when
it comes to the white
room is that Jean Grey is basically able
to take those individuals to sort of
Usher them to the afterlife this is the
only instance that I believe I've ever
seen Jean Grey lead anybody to the
afterlife but it does bring that into
the equation and it does say it's
possible but it is kind of interesting
because it does bring a lot of these
things into fray and so ultimately what
is of happening is that with her entire
family being totally eradicated by this
assassin group from the Shiar Empire
what is up happening here is Rachel
summers basically swears revenge and so
what this is going to do is lead
directly into the events of deadly
Genesis it's going to lead into the
events of Rachel summers coming across
Vulcan Vulcan basically waking up and
then her meeting in a meta-level mutant
so powerful that he can overwhelm and
overpower Rachel summers even with the
power of the Phoenix force but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come as explained and make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you